let's bring in Dave Rubin he's host of
the Rubin report just before we got that
update from mayor Adams we're talking
about the Rivalry I guess between
Governor Newsom and Governor DeSantis I
say rivalry because with a smile I think
that Governor Newsom thinks he's in a
rivalry with Ron DeSantis and that
Rhonda Santos is like I'm not worried
about you you're like you know Little
League Baseball compared to where he is
in terms of the major leagues running
for president governor Newsom if you
want to run for president go ahead and
go for it he says in a tweet about
Governor Newsom you small Newsome says
about DeSantis you small pathetic man
this isn't Martha's Vineyard kidnapping
charges with a question mark because
he's not even sure if that actually
would apply here he just wanted to get
in the news Dave Rubin what do you think
well in that over a million people I
think 1.3 million people have fled
California in the last three years the
majority of them going to Florida I
think you can figure out who the people
actually like and who they're running
from but even before we get into the two
of them look the first blame here goes
to the Biden Administration for not
protecting the Border it's the federal
government's job to do that so that
that's important to just qualify this
with but look at the end of the day
Gavin Newsom should be thrilled right
now Gavin Newsom wants to run a
sanctuary State he says he loves illegal
immigrants who by definition are
breaking the law by coming to this
country not through legal means and he
should be very excited that he can put
them in some of the empty buildings that
are in Los Angeles or San Francisco and
they can become part of the community
and he can give them phones and the rest
of it what we're seeing here right now
is the very clear distinction between
the two roads that America can go down
and Americans really have to decide
which one they want to do we can either
have Law and Order we can have legal in
immigration we can have policing that
actually works and is funded we can be a
society that is based in law or we can
just let anyone come do whatever they
want give them Services put all those uh
services on the back of the taxpayer and
I think it's very obvious what Americans
want that's why Gavin Newsom seems so
hysterical it's also why he put the
question mark in that because he knows
he also said this NBC Dave you said now
ultimately who's accountable and
responsible I mean the buck should stop
with Rhonda Santos and the games he's
playing but it's the folks on the front
line are doing the Dirty Work and that's
ultimately what we have to determine is
where the culpa building lands and
resides you said it California considers
itself Gavin Newsom may not know that
Ron DeSantis is not president yet
hopefully he will be president one day
and then we can blame him if there's a
problem at the border but he's not
president yet that's his guy although I
think it's the guy he's trying to take
out Joe Biden but that's a different
topic altogether well the other thing
that does is it gives Rhonda Santos a
way to get in the news with some earned
media and not you know a campaign stunt
because it's in a crowded field it is
difficult to figure out a way how can
you stand out and this I don't know if
Governor Newsom realizes it actually
helps Ron DeSantis and a Republican
primary by being able to talk about it
of course there's no one in Florida or
on the Republican or roughly
conservative side of things that looks
at this and is like oh no this is a
bridge too far for Rhonda Santos Rhonda
santis is doing what the federal
government will not and he's
consistently done that so again Gavin
Newsom by his own policies by the own
policies of Eric Adams who you just
showed at the press conference in New
York these guys say we are Sanctuary
States we are Sanctuary cities nobody is
illegal you know all the the meaningless
slogans so they should be thrilled when
they get more of these people again the
key thing is that this is about illegal
immigration not legal immigration so
Gavin Newsom I just don't know where
he's standing on this because you're
getting more people it's very exciting
Gab Dave thanks Dave Rubin who lives in
Florida yes thanks for paying attention
to all of this for us and coming to tell
us your thoughts great to have you good
seeing you guys if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of mindless
dribble check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell